Trascrizione: Piero Cavallo
Revisore: Barbara Dalla Villa
(musica)
Bene, quando sono stato invitato
a questo evento
e mi è stato detto
che il tema era “remare”,
francamente ho sorriso
perché c’è poco da fare,
nel bene o nel male,
la vita sa sempre sorprenderci.
Non avrei mai immaginato
che mi sarebbe stata data la possibilità
di parlare di tutte quante
le remate controcorrente
fatte in questi ultimi 22 anni.
Perché per fare ricerca bisogna remare
controcorrente e resistere.
Io mi chiamo Francesco Maranpon,
ho 43 anni, sono un medico
e sono specializzato
in radioterapia oncologica.
In altre parole,
mi occupo di curare i tumori
utilizzando le radiazioni ionizzanti.
Sono abruzzese d’adozione,
da 22 anni vivo a L’Aquila.
Ho sposato una donna di Ortona
per cui la cittadinanza la merito tutta.
Ho una passione:
quella di parlare con le cellule.
Perché che voi lo sappiate o meno,
le cellule parlano.
Utilizzano un linguaggio molto complicato,
un linguaggio molecolare
che ha un ruolo essenziale, cioè:
nella cellula normale mantiene
il funzionamento dei tessuti,
in quella patologica,
ad esempio in quella neoplastica,
ne garantisce
la proliferazione incontrollata,
la capacità di metastatizzare,
di non rispondere alle terapie.
La cosa ancora più interessante è che
ogni tumore ha un suo linguaggio alterato
e che è stato recentemente scoperto
che all’interno di uno stesso tumore
esiste una piccola
sotto-popolazione di cellule,
che prende il nome
di cellule staminali cancerose,
che sono le reali responsabili
della crescita del tumore
e che hanno un linguaggio tutto loro.
Cosa peggiore,
pazienti con una stessa neoplasia
hanno cellule staminali
che possono utilizzare
linguaggi completamente differenti.
Io negli ultimi 22 anni ho tentato
di parlare con il rabdomiosarcoma
che è un tumore abbastanza raro,
ma è il più frequente tumore
dei tessuti molli
in soggetti di età pediatrica.
Vi racconto questi 22 anni
in quattro capitoli.
Il primo l’ho intitolato
“imparare a remare contro corrente”.
Quando sei giovane hai una potenza
che è impressionante.
Se hai passione,
se hai il “sacro fuoco”, si chiama,
puoi fare quello che vuoi.
Io ho avuto la fortuna di entrare
in un laboratorio di persone
che davano spazio ai giovani,
lasciavano pensare.
Con un limite: questo laboratorio
aveva pochissimi soldi.
Ora, quando si parla di ricerca
si parla sempre di soldi.
Se hai pochi soldi,
non puoi fare ricerca: non è vero.
Ci sono sempre delle vie collaterali
che magari rendono molto più lento
l’ottenimento del dato, ma è possibile.
E così, molto brevemente,
noi siamo i primi a scoprire
che il rabdomiosarcoma utilizza
un linguaggio particolare
per sopravvivere.
A volte la ricerca è come il vino rosso
in botte: migliora dopo tanti anni.
Ed è proprio quest’anno che in America
sono stati presentati i primi dati
sull’utilizzo di un farmaco che distrugge
questo linguaggio e che sta migliorando
la sopravvivenza dei pazienti affetti
da rabdomiosarcoma pediatrico.
Ora, è talmente tanta la passione,
che pur non avendo soldi noi dimostriamo
che questo linguaggio permette l’accumulo
di una proteina pirata, la c-Myc.
fa quello che vuole all’interno
della cellula, bisogna distruggerla.
Beh qui servono soldi, noi non ne abbiamo.
L’unica soluzione è la solita,
che abbiamo sentito tante volte in TV:
emigrare, andare in America
In America l’acqua non è calma come qui.
Il livello di competizione
è nettamente più elevato.
Ma poco importa: se hai voglia di lavorare
sono talmente tante le risorse
che i risultati arrivano.
Del capitolo americano
non vi voglio parlare
da un punto di vista scientifico.
Quello che mi ha colpito è stata
la possibilità di vedere il nostro Paese
da un balcone distante
quindi di apprezzarne le potenzialità
ma anche di sottolinearne i criticismi.
Ho conosciuto tantissimi di quelli
che comunemente sentiamo chiamare
cervelli in fuga,
che invece a me piace chiamare
cervelli messi in fuga,
che è una cosa completamente differente.
Ma in America ho la fortuna di conoscere,
di approfondire la radioterapia.
La radioterapia è la disciplina medica
che ha subito negli ultimi 20 anni
l'evoluzione maggiore.
Oggi esistono delle macchine che sono
in grado di colpire un piccolo tumore
con una potenza pazzesca
risparmiando i tessuti sani.
Solo che ci sono alcuni tumori come
i rabdomiosarcomi che tendono a sfuggire
perché forse utilizzano un linguaggio
che ne garantisce la radio-resistenza.
Da dieci anni esiste una linea di ricerca
che cerca di capire questo linguaggio.
È l’occasione per tornare in Italia,
perché voglio tornare in Italia,
nel mio Paese, mettere su un laboratorio
che studi questo meccanismo.
Qui si apre il capitolo peggiore
di tutta questa storia.
Probabilmente voi ricorderete
questa immagine.
Sono le 3:32 del 6 aprile del 2009.
Il terremoto colpisce l’Aquila.
Si scappa da casa, con mia moglie
tentiamo di prendere le scale,
ma le scale non ci sono
o quantomeno non si vedono.
Si accende una sorta di lampada, ricordo.
Le scale c’erano,
si erano staccate dal muro.
Andiamo in ospedale, lì lavoriamo,
conosciamo le persone,
facciamo entrambi la specializzazione.
Si monta in macchina che era finita
in una specie di burrone.
C’è una strana nebbia.
A L’Aquila poi la nebbia...
Non era la nebbia: era la polvere
che avevano alzato le macerie.
Non importa, andiamo in ospedale aiutiamo
primo giorno, secondo giorno.
A un certo punto torna in mente
il laboratorio.
Che fine avrà fatto?
È inutile.
Troppe persone in questi anni
ti hanno detto che è difficile
fare ricerca scientifica in Italia.
Un evento del genere mette un punto,
ma poi ci penso e dico: ma cavolo,
ci sono persone che col terremoto
hanno perso molto più di un laboratorio.
Allora vale la pena tornare,
prendere i piccoli pezzettini.
Stavolta i pezzettini sono troppo pochi,
i soldi non ci sono, non si riparte.
A un certo punto viene un’idea:
le case farmaceutiche
in America richiedevano
un service dove lavoravo,
cioè ti chiedevano
di fare degli esperimenti per testare
se un eventuale farmaco
avesse una potenzialità
come trattamento anti-neoplastico.
Proponiamo il nostro laboratorio
ma a un prezzo nettamente inferiore
semplicemente perché non chiediamo
di essere pagati come persone
ma solo il materiale.
Il laboratorio riparte, collaboriamo
con moltissime case farmaceutiche,
ma ecco l’ennesima difficoltà.
Purtroppo la scuola
di specializzazione finisce.
Quando finisce una scuola
di specializzazione per un medico
c’è solo un percorso da fare:
quello di tentare i concorsi,
andare a lavorare per la specializzazione
per cui si è studiato.
Questo per me voleva dire andare via
dall’Abruzzo, andare via da L’Aquila,
chiudere definitivamente il laboratorio.
Il problema è che in quel laboratorio
stavamo crescendo tre persone,
tre giovani con una voglia pazzesca.
Per cui decido di scommettere nuovamente
e faccio una cosa che nessun medico,
pochi medici disperati fanno.
All’inizio vado a lavorare
in un carcere.
A L’Aquila c’è il carcere più grande
d’Europa con regime 41bis.
È un’esperienza surreale perché conosco
tutti quanti quei personaggi
che oggi dominano le fiction o dei quali
si sente parlare nei telegiornali.
Sette anni, non sono stati pochi.
Parallelamente lavoro in un hospice
che forse è stata l’esperienza
più importante perché
in hospice tu conosci i pazienti
dove la terapia è fallita.
Quindi il fallimento della terapia c’è
e va contrastato.
Solo la ricerca scientifica può farlo.
In questo periodo, con molta difficoltà,
siamo i primi al mondo
a isolare le cellule staminali
di rabdomiosarcoma.
L'ultimo capitolo.
Spesso diciamo che è sbagliato
guardarsi indietro.
Secondo me non è così.
Mantenere la marcia sì,
ma girarsi ogni tanto, voltarsi
e rendersi conto che si è costruito
qualcosa, non è sbagliato.
Io metto insieme tutto e propongo
a varie università la mia figura.
È di pochi giorni fa la presa
di una posizione in Sapienza.
Ma soprattutto,
è di pochi giorni fa una notizia
ancora più importante se vogliamo.
In questi 22 anni abbiamo speso
tantissime energie e tantissimi soldi
nel costruire un modello
per lo studio della radioresistenza
nel rabdomiosarcoma.
Questo è il primo modello al mondo.
Intorno a questo modello
costruiamo un progetto.
Scrivere un progetto è la cosa
più complicata che si può fare,
almeno per chi fa ricerca scientifica.
Lo sottoponiamo all’Associazione Italiana
per la Ricerca contro il Cancro.
Questo progetto è stato finanziato
con quasi 800 mila euro,
per un periodo di circa 5 anni.
Io ho terminato.
Voglio lasciare tre messaggi.
Il primo: da soli non si fa nulla.
È impossibile, specialmente
nella ricerca scientifica.
Ma credo in qualsiasi cosa nella vita.
Questo è un network di persone
che ho costruito negli ultimi 10-15 anni
con cui lavoro benissimo.
Secondo messaggio che fa riferimento
a Charles Darwin:
sono centinaia di anni che viene mandato
sempre lo stesso messaggio:
i giovani d’oggi non servono a nulla.
È un messaggio sbagliato.
Le generazioni andando avanti
non fanno altro che migliorare.
Dico ai giovani: non fatevi fregare,
se potete correte i vostri rischi,
conquistate le vostre paure
e remate, remate, remate.
Infine, a chi ha deciso
di fare il mio lavoro,
e spesso chi fa il mio lavoro
decide di abbandonare tutto,
lascio un proverbio cinese che dice:
imparare è come remare controcorrente,
appena smetti, torni indietro.
Grazie a tutti.